Es hora de preguntarnos,
si las suposiciones y políticas
desarrolladas a raíz de esos eventos trágicos
realmente nos hicieron más seguros.
¿Han hecho a nuestras sociedades tanto en Europa como en EE. UU.
más resilientes?
He trabajado toda mi vida en el ámbito de la seguridad y la defensa,
y estoy convencida de que ahora, más que nunca,
debemos replantearnos radicalmente cómo pensamos y actuamos
en materia de seguridad y, especialmente, sobre seguridad internacional.
Con seguridad internacional, realmente me refiero a qué hacemos,
cómo preparamos nuestros países
para responder mejor y prevenir amenazas externas,
y cómo protegemos a nuestros ciudadanos.
La clave para ambos
es enfocarse en proteger a los civiles,
tanto en nuestros propios países
como en aquellos donde estamos presentes en nombre de la seguridad.
Esta idea va en contra de la narrativa fija
que desarrollamos en los últimos 20 años
sobre qué es la seguridad y cómo lograrla,
pero esa narrativa es defectuosa y, lo que es peor, es contraproducente.
Durante los últimos 20 años,
tanto en EE. UU. como en Europa,
hemos llegado a aceptar que hay que hablar de seguridad en términos de suma cero,
como si la única forma de lograr más seguridad
fuera comprometer los valores y los derechos:
seguridad en oposición a derechos humanos,
seguridad en oposición a libertad y desarrollo.
Esta es una falsa oposición.
Simplemente no funciona así.
Necesitamos reconocer
que la seguridad y los derechos humanos no son valores opuestos,
están intrínsecamente relacionados.
Después de todo, el derecho humano más básico
es el derecho a vivir y a estar libre de violencia,
y la responsabilidad más básica de un estado
es garantizar ese derecho a sus ciudadanos.
Por el contrario, si pensamos en comunidades de todo el mundo
afectadas por la guerra y el conflicto,
es la inseguridad y la violencia
lo que les impide alcanzar su plena libertad y desarrollo.
Necesitan seguridad básica tanto como nosotros
y la necesitan para poder vivir una vida normal
y para poder disfrutar de sus derechos humanos.
Por eso tenemos que cambiar.
Debemos reconocer que la seguridad sostenible
se construye sobre una base de derechos humanos,
se basa en la promoción y el respeto de los derechos humanos.
Además, en las últimas dos décadas,
hemos aceptado que la mejor manera de garantizar nuestra propia seguridad
es derrotando a nuestros enemigos,
y para hacer eso, debemos confiar casi exclusivamente en el ejército.
De nuevo, esto choca con mi trabajo, con mi investigación,
con lo que veo en el campo.
Lo que veo es que construir seguridad sostenible
tiene mucho menos que ver con aplastar a los enemigos,
tiene mucho menos que ver con ganar en el campo de batalla,
y tiene mucho más que ver con proteger a las víctimas
y construir estabilidad.
Y para logar eso, solo con militares
es simplemente insuficiente.
Por esa razón creo que hay dejar de lado la guerra sin fin contra el terror
y reemplazarla por una agenda de seguridad
impulsada por el principio de protección a los civiles,
no importa de dónde sean, qué pasaporte tengan
o dónde vivan
Vancouver, Nueva York,
Kabul, Mosul, Aleppo o Douma.
La seguridad sostenible nos muestra que somos más propensos
a tener seguridad a largo plazo en casa para nosotros,
si enfocamos nuestros compromisos en el exterior para proteger a los civiles
y para garantizar que sus vidas se vivan con dignidad y sin violencia.
Por ejemplo, todos sabemos que derrotar a ISIS
es un logro de seguridad.
Absolutamente.
Pero reconstruir casas destruidas,
restaurar el orden,
asegurar un sistema político representativo,
es tan importante, si no más importante,
y no solo para la seguridad de los civiles en Iraq y en Siria,
sino para nuestra propia seguridad y estabilidad global.
Más fundamentalmente,
el peligro del ISIS no debe contarse solo en la cantidad de armas que posee,
sino también en el número de niños que han sacado de la escuela
o adoctrinado.
Esto es así desde una perspectiva de seguridad.
Desde una perspectiva de seguridad,
el impacto generacional a largo plazo de tener millones de niños en Siria
conociendo solo guerra y sin ir a la escuela,
es una amenaza mucho más peligrosa para la estabilidad
que todas las armas del ISIS combinadas,
y deberíamos invertir el mismo tiempo y la misma energía para contrarrestar esto
que la que invertimos luchando contra ISIS militarmente.
En las últimas dos décadas
nuestra política de seguridad ha sido cortoplacista.
Se ha centrado en el aquí y ahora.
Se ha minimizado sistemáticamente el vínculo entre lo que hacemos hoy
en nombre de la seguridad
y el impacto a largo plazo de esas decisiones.
En los años posteriores al 11 de septiembre
algunas de las opciones,
algunas de las políticas que implementamos
probablemente no nos han hecho más seguros a largo plazo.
La seguridad sostenible y centrada en el ciudadano
debe ver lo que sucede a largo plazo.
De nuevo, por ejemplo, confiar en los drones
para atacar a los enemigos en países lejanos puede ser una herramienta.
Puede ser una herramienta para asegurarse o disminuir la amenaza
de un ataque inminente a EE. UU.
Pero ¿qué pasa con el impacto a largo plazo?
Si los civiles son asesinados,
si las comunidades son el objetivo,
esto alimentará un círculo vicioso
de guerra, conflicto, trauma y radicalización,
y ese círculo vicioso está en el centro de muchos de los desafíos de seguridad
a los que nos enfrentamos hoy.
Esto no nos hace más seguros a largo plazo.
Necesitamos seguridad civil,
necesitamos una seguridad sostenible centrada en los civiles,
y la necesitamos ahora.
Debemos alentar el pensamiento y la investigación en torno a este concepto
e implementarlo.
Vivimos en un mundo peligroso.
Hay muchas amenazas a la paz y muchos conflictos.
Como en los días posteriores al 11 de septiembre,
simplemente no podemos permitirnos no pensar en la seguridad internacional.
Pero tenemos que aprender de las lecciones de los últimos 20 años.
Para hacerlo bien, para obtener la seguridad correcta,
necesitamos enfocarnos en el largo plazo.
Necesitamos enfocarnos en proteger a los civiles.
Y debemos respetar y reconocer el hecho
de que la seguridad sostenible se basa en los derechos humanos.
De lo contrario, en nombre de la seguridad,
corremos el riesgo de hacer del mundo
un lugar mucho más peligroso e inestable
de lo que ya era.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)